then my guys it's me markiplier you've
probably been wondering where the hell I
am
and it's these guys fault that I am the
waiter this is this is Tyler this is
waiting this is Bob and this is he found
and so we as friends have decided to
start a building on a show together and
in this show that we're building
together we share love and are
practicing for the live show that we are
doing this June it's coming together
great isn't that right guys so when we
play the games that we're gonna play it
again anyway so the show is gonna be
done soon and we're doing great work and
it's a lot of fun the videos have been
wonky so that's where I've been so we're
gonna keep not funny
we're gonna keep going with the
practicing and then we'll see you with
ticket sales and show Nate's very soon
sound good okay